so a little bit of some background about
this talk of war why I presented this
these are pretty much lessons learned
while I was working at no source
previously I was doing like consulting
work as a Solutions Architect basing the
customer making sure they were using
nodejs properly and they were
successfully using node and I saw a lot
of different bad patterns out there on
whole other companies were doing error
handling and especially when the process
were crashing or the process were dying
they didn't have enough visibility they
didn't have like login strategies in
place they were like missing the very
important information about why the node
processes were having issues or we're
crashing they were experiencing downtime
and we're satellite to collecting a set
of best practices and recommendations
for them that are aligned with the
overall nodejs community if you go to
the documentation there are going to be
pretty much the same recommendations I'm
going to be speaking about today we're a
couple other more more things to make
sure you have like a very good exit
strategy for it for your node.js
processes these best practices apply
it's pretty much for web and network
based applications because we are going
to cover also the graceful shutdown but
you can use them for all the type of
nodejs applications that are constantly
running and no sadly is not there long
way if you know about airline or leaks
you they let it crash it's just like a
term that it's very common in that in
that community when I started learning
airline back in 2014
I loved the fault tolerance options that
this platform and language has and I
always think about how to bring the same
experience internal two years is not the
same because you can do whole code
reloading or function swap you know node
you can do those things on air long but
still know this pretty lightweight and
you can like easily restart and recover
from from a crash first before getting
into the bad the bad place or when bad
things happen how to make sure that
everything is good what do we need to do
two or node application to make sure
they are running properly so first sir
recommendation and there are going to be
a workshop later about this specific
clean clothes native Jas demeans this
workshop I by Beth she's going to also
mention about like Oh to add health
checks to you know dues processes so
pretty much as our recommendation at a
health check route it's a simple route
that is going to return a 200 status
code and you will need to set something
to monitor that route you can do it on
other at your load balancer level if you
are using a reverse proxy or load
balancer like in genetics or HM proxy or
you are using
ldea will be any type of application
that is being the top layer of your
node.js process being constantly
monitoring that the health check is
returning okay so you are making sure
that everything is fine and also rely on
APM some tools that are going to monitor
the performance and the health of your
noj's processes so in order to make sure
that everything is running fine you will
need to have tools some like very known
tools like New Relic uh dynamics
dynaTrace and sorry there like a lot of
them in the in the market will give you
way more visibility around the health of
you know various processes and you can
like leave like in peace when when you
are like making sure your node is
running properly
but what to do if something bad and
unexpected happens
so what should we do with our nodejs
processes letting them crash so if
something bad and unexpected happened
I will let my notice process crash but
in order to be able to do it it dry we
will need to implement that I said those
best practices and follow some sort of
office steps to make sure that the or
application is going to restart properly
and continue running and serve into
customers and clients before letting it
crash we will need to learn about the
process lifecycle especially on the
shutdown side of things some error
handling best practices there is there
is going to be and also another very
recommended workshop around it I'm not
going to be covering how to properly
handle errors in ojs just on on shutdown
and this is pretty much so you can stop
worrying about unexpected errors and
increase visibility of your nodejs
processes increase visibility of what
happened when your process crashes and
what might be the reason so you can fix
it and iterate over your application so
similar to coming back to the airline
concept and no genius process is very
lightweight it's a small in memory it
doesn't have like a very big memory
footprint and the idea is to keep the
processes very lean
at a startup so they can start like
super fast if you have a lot of
operations like high intensity to you
CPU or synchronous operations other
startup it might decrease the the
ability to restart like super fuzzy or
nauseas processes so try to keep your
process is very lean on the startup use
the strategies like prevail Dean so you
are not going to build on a start-up or
on the bootstrap of your process do
everything before you are going to start
your process and if something unexpected
and that happens just exit and they
start a new no genius process as soon as
possible to avoid on time and pretty
much this is called a restart
you are late in the process crash and
then start a new one but we will need to
have some sort of tools in place and
settings to be able to have something
that restarts of or no genius processes
so let's learn how to exit an arduous
process so there are like two common
methods on the process module that will
help you
shut down or terminate a node.js process
the the most common one is the process
of exit you can pass an exit code the
zero if it is a success exit or higher
than zero commonly one if it is a
failure and this pretty much instructs
not GS to end a process with the
specified exit code there is the other
one which is the process dot abort with
the process daughterboard is going to
cost no js' process to exit immediately
and generate a core file if your
operating system has core dumps enabled
so in order to be able to have like more
visibility on post-mortem debugging to
be able to see what happened or what
class you know genius process if there
is like a memory memory issue you can
call process dot abort it will generate
a core dump and then you can use tools
like ll node which is a plug-in for ll
DVD to do like c and c++ debugging of
the core DOM and to see what might
happen in the native side of no J's when
you process scratch so those are like
the two options you have to exit on ojs
process how to handle accident extra
balance so nodejs means two different or
two main events when your no js' process
is exiting one is the before exit so the
before exit the band it's a handle that
can make asynchronous calls and the even
loop will continue to work until it
finishes so before the process is it's
ending you can schedule more work on the
on the level loop do more a synchronous
task and then you can clean up your
process this event is not emitted on
conditions that are causing like
explicit termination like on an encore
reception or when I explicitly call
process directs it so this is on other
other exits a scenarios and the exit
event it's a handle also can't
make asynchronous call only synchronous
calls can happen in this part of the
process lifecycle because they even loop
doesn't have any more work to do so the
event loop is passed in here so if you
try to do any synchronous calling here
is not going to be executed only
synchronous calls can't happen here and
this event is a minute when process
Exodus colic it's called explicitly it's
commonly used if you want to log at the
end some information when you process
exit like my process exit with there is
a specific exit code and you want to add
some more context around the state of
your application at the time that that
the process exited some examples going
to use it you attach those events on on
the process module that before exit can
do like synchronous code so that set
timeout even though the event loop is
paused at that moment when you schedule
more asynchronous work it will resume
the event loop and continue until there
is no more work to do there is one thing
I want to mention here is that normally
I know Jes process exits when there is
no more work schedule on the Evan loop
when there is nothing else on the evolu
a process is going to exit why a server
keeps running because it has a handle
register on the Evan loop like a socket
waiting waiting for connections and
that's why I web server it's constantly
running until you close the server or
you interrupt the process otherwise if
there is something register on the Evan
loop the nodejs process is continuing
its content is going to continue running
so in this case I execute set timeout
scheduled more work it will continue
working until there is no more no more
left to do a process on exit
pretty much just AC it just synchronous
calls I can do anything here with the
other loop they have an lowest oral pass
useful for login information or saving
the state of the application and exit
there is also
a couple of signal events that are going
to be useful on on shutdown there is the
sick term and sick in sick term it is
normally immediate when a process
monitor send a signal termination to
your notice process to tell them that
there is going to be like a successful
way to chop down your process like when
you execute like on system de or using
op starred when you send like a stop
that service or stop the process it's
going to send a sick term to your no js'
process and you can handle that event
and do some sort of work on that
specific part of the lifecycle and the
sick in it's an interruption it is
immediate when you interrupt the no
genius processes normally when you do
control see when you are running on the
console you can also capture that event
and do some work around it so these are
like two ways to expect Lee finalized an
odorous process so these two events are
considered a successful termination this
is why I'm exiting here with the exit
code zero because it is something that
it's expected I say I don't want this
process to continue running and the
results of the error events so they are
like two main events one it's the on
Quora ception the infamous on corruption
and recently when promises were
introduced into node their 100 rejection
so the intersection is immediate when a
javascript error is not properly handled
so it pretty much represents a
programmer error or represents a bug in
your code if an unco reception happens
the like the recommendation is to always
crash your process let it crash don't
try to recover from an interception
because it might give you some sort of
troubles and while even though the
community is not is it's not totally
agree on the second one I will say the
same for an 100 rejection and 100 Roger
it is immediate when a promise is
rejected and there is no hundred
attached to the promise so there is no
catch attached to the promise in my
represent an operational error in my
representing a programmer error
so it depends off of what happened here
but both of those cases it's better to
log as much information as possible
treat those as p1 issues that needs to
be fixed in the next iteration or in the
next release so if you don't have any
strategy in place to be able to identify
why your processes are crashing and you
are not fixing and handling those
properly your application are going to
remain having having box so if it is a
non conception that's a bug that's a
programming error that is something that
is not expected please crash log and
file an issues so that needs to be fixed
if it is under 100 rejection C if B
seats like a a programmer error or if
it's an operational error that needs to
be handled and go update the code at the
proper handling to that promise and
continue with your with your job so as I
said in both cases an error event it's
cause of termination for noobs for you
know J's process always exit the process
with an exit code different than zero so
it's going to be one so your process
monitor and your logs know the it was a
failure
and as I say don't try to recover from
our non-core reception well I was
working as a consultant so a lot of
people trying to do a lot of magic to
avoid the node.js processes dying by
adding some complex logic on during
conception and that always ended your
application on a bad state or having
memory leaks or having like sockets
hanging and it was kind of a mess so
it's cheaper to let it crash start a new
process from from a scratch and continue
receiving more requests so a couple of
examples on conception and rejection
don't curry
exception received such an argument and
error instance so you get the
information about the error that was
thrown or and that was in handling
journalist code and the 100 rejection is
going to give you a reason which can be
an error instance - and it will give you
the promise that was that was not
properly handled so those are like
useful information that you can have in
your logs to have more information where
things are failing in your in your code
but we saw how to handle events how to
handle the errors some of the best
practices but how to do it properly what
we do what we need to do better to be
able to have our very good shut down a
strategy for remote areas processes so
the first one it's running more than one
process at the same time so rely of
horizontally scaling load balance your
word processes having more than one so
in that way if one of those process
crashes there is another process that it
needs Ally and it's able to receive
requests so it will give you time to do
the restart and all the requests are
coming in and maybe the only issue you
are going to have are with the requests
that were already happening in the node
areas process that crashes but this is
going to give you a little bit more
leverage and prevent don't I'm and what
we use for load balancing use whatever
you have in hand if it's nginx or a chip
proxy as a reverse proxy for your
node.js applications if you are on AWS
or on the cloud you can use their
elastic load balancer application load
balancers or the order load balancer
solutions that cloud offers if you are
on Kira Nerys you can using grace or
other different load balancing
strategies for your application so
pretty much make sure that you have more
than one no Jarius process running so
you can be more in peace if one of those
processes crashes you will need to have
process monitoring and process
monitoring needs
much something that is running in your
operating system or an application that
it's constantly checking if your process
is alive or not if it crashes if there
is a failure the process monitor is in
charge of restoring the process so the
recommendation is to always use the
native process monitoring that it's
available in your operating system if it
is UNIX or Linux you can use system D or
AB start I specifically are in the
restart on failure or respond when you
are working on off start if you are
using containers use whatever is
available docker has the restore option
kubernetes has the restore policy and
you can also configure your processes to
restart when it fails to retry a number
of times so you don't go into like a
crazy error that is going to constantly
make your application crash and you end
up in the crash loop so you can add like
some sort of like retries into there but
always have a process monitoring in
place if you can't use any of any of
these tools as a last resource but not
recommended use a no js' process
monitoring like p.m. - or forever but I
will not recommend these to any customer
of mine or any frame but if you don't
have any any any more resource if you
can use the native stuff in your
operating system or if you are not using
containers you can go this way these
tools are good for development don't get
me wrong if you are low on development
they're like very good tools to restore
your processes when they crashes but for
production they might not be the best
let's talk about a little bit a graceful
shutdown so we have a web server running
the web server is getting requests and
it's getting connections and we have
some established connections between our
customers or our clients and the server
but what happened with the process
crashes when the process crashes if we
are not doing a graceful shutdown some
of those sockets are going to
to to be kept hand hanging and they're
going to wait until a timeout is being
reach and that might cost on time and
decrease the experience of of your users
so it is better so set up a known
reference timeout that is going to let
the server do its job so we will need to
close the server explicitly say to the
server stop receiving connections so
they can reject the new connection so
new connections are going to be going to
the new or to the other project the
other nodejs process that is running
through the load balancer and it will be
able to send a fiend packet participate
is EP fin packet to the to the clients
that are already connected so they are
going to be finishing the connection
immediately when the server dies they
are not going to stay waiting until a
time out of this reach out they are
going to be closing that connection and
on this on the next retry we expect that
the process has restarted and at that
point or they go to another process that
is running so one example of that a on
reference timeout when we are handling
the signal or error event which is the
shutdown part of the life cycle what we
can do is to explicitly call server
closed if it is an instance of the net
server which is the same one that uses
the HTTP or HTTPS known modules you can
pass a callback so when it finishes
closing the connection it will exit the
process successfully but we will need to
have a timeout in place because we don't
we don't want to wait for a long time
imagine if we have like a lot of
different clients connected that it's
taking a lot of time to clean clean up
those those processes we need to have
some sort of way to to have an internal
timeout so here we are scheduling a new
timeout but that timeout is not on the
evolu that last part the unread
is not the scheduling the timeout on the
event loop so it is not adding more
world to the heaven loop so when the
timeout is reach or the server close
callback is reach either of those paths
are going to close the nodejs process so
this is kind of like a race between the
two between your timeout that is not on
the evolu or between the server close
whichever works better and what timeout
time we we do need to put here depending
on the needs of your applications we had
customers that had they need to have
like very very few timeouts or a small
timeout because they were like doing a
lot of real-time trading and they need
in the processes to restart as far as as
far as possible there are orders that
can have like longer timeouts to let all
of the connection finishes this is the
pencil of the use case if you do not
they on ref in here since this timeout
is going to be a schedule on the heaven
loop it's going to wait until it
finishes and the process is going to end
so this is like a safeguard so there is
no more work as scheduled on they even
loop where while we are excellent
process logging this is one of the most
important parts of having a very good
exit the strategy for remote for your
node.js processes so implement a robust
login a strategy for your application
especially on shutdown if I never
happens please log as much information
as possible an error object will contain
not only the message or the cause of the
error body but will also contain the
stack trace so if you log the stack
trace you will be able to come back to
your code and fix and look at
specifically white fail and where they
fail and you can rely on libraries like
Pino or Winston and use transport to
store the logs in an external service
you can use like Splunk or paper trail
or use whatever whatever you like to
store the logs but have a way to always
go back to the logs
search for those on cara's
ha the rejections and being able to
identify why your processes are crushing
fix those issues and continue with your
work so how can we put these all
together I have like some sort of
pattern I use of my projects but there
is also a lot of modules on NPM that are
going to do the same thing even better
than then the approach I'm following
here so this is kind of apparent I use I
create a module called
terminate or I use like a file called
terminate I pass the server like the
instance of that cerebrum that I'm going
to be closing and so on configuration
options if I want to enable core dumps
or not and the timeout usually when I
want to enable the core dump of Nod I
use an environment variable when I am
going to do like some sort of
performance testing on my application or
I want to replicate the error so I
enable the core domes I let it crash
with the process to the board I check
out the core dump and get more
information about it so here I have our
exit function that switches between the
abort or they or the process that exit
depending of the configuration you have
here the rest I'm returning a function
that returns a function and that
function is the one that I'm going to be
using as the exit Handler and this is
pretty much the code that I'm going to
be using for on Quora sections on
hundred rejections and signals and here
log as much as possible I'm using
console.log for simplicity but please
use a proper logging library here and
pretty much if there is an error and if
that is an instance of the error I want
to get information about the message and
the stack trace and at the end I'm going
to be trying doing the graceful shutdown
so this is the same the same thing I
explained before I will close the server
and also I will refer
have a timeout to also close the server
after that timeout happens so it depends
whatever ends first and how to use these
this is more module I have here this is
an example I have an issue that DB
server I have my terminate code that I
use for my project I create an exit
handler with the options with the server
I'm running with the different
parameters I want to pass in to my exit
Handler and I attach that function into
the different events so here exit
Handler on an encore inception and an
one hundred rejection I'm going to
return an exit code of one and I can add
like a message to my logs to to say what
type of error or what type of handli
handling was this and also with the
signals and with the signals I'm passing
like an exit code of zero because it is
something that there isn't to be
successful so this is pretty much what I
have for today and the presentation some
resources that are going to be useful
for you please don't miss Rubin
Bridgewater workshop later today it's
going to be called error handling doing
it right he's going to be explaining now
whole whole table of it get in here Jota
boy getting into danke reception side of
things how to properly create there were
objects to have more visibility how to
handle a handle promises rejections so
this is a these are going to be a very
good presentation and also the cloud
native J is by Beth she's going to be
mentioning also how to add monitor
interrupt to your application health
checks so those are going to be good
things if you want to run nodejs
properly in production some MP amoi
jewels to take a look that pretty much
solves the issue I was talking about
today there is a module I like the
terminals by the team abroad re a it
supports our in health checks to your
application it has C signal handlers to
it has a very good a graceful choke down
a strategy way more complex
that the 1i I presented you and this is
something that you cannot do your
projects pretty easily just create an
instance of terminals configurated and
add the different hundreds there there
is also another module called stoppable
stoppable is a decorator over the server
class that is going to be able to
implement not the close a function but
like a stop function and it's going to
be also doing a lot of things around
graceful shutdown and there is also a
module that pretty much it's what I
presented today it's called HTTP
graceful shutdown you also pass an
instance of your HTTP server and it has
like different handlers of you can like
see what happened when there is an error
or where is or what kind of signals I'm
going to be monitoring the promoters are
going to be resources that are going to
simplify your life and make you better
at running know the production and you
will be able to let it crash one last
thing I want to invite you to note conf
Columbia so save the date is going to
happen June 26 and 27 2020 we did happen
in managing Columbia more information no
dot Co CFP is not open yet but I will
expect a lot of you all
sending proposals to go to me the gene
we pay for travel we pay for hotel and
if you want to know a little bit about
the experience of speaking at a
conference in Columbia you can ask James
you can ask Anna and I think you cannot
Brian there is like a couple of folks
here that have is spoken there and thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]